this program is brought to you by Emory
University Harry Potter the Boy Who
Lived come to die let's finish this the
way we started together
you'll stay with me oh my until the end
we have in the Harry Potter series a
great deal of philosophy we have words
from Plato ideas from Plato ideas from
Aristotle ideas from mil and ideas from
other other major philosophers but then
we also have great influences from
Tolkien from CS Lewis from writers that
we've connected with in the past CS
Lewis's messages were often about his
views on Christianity his views on
morality his views on what it meant to
be good and evil rallying is doing
exactly the same thing that's one of the
reasons I find it fascinating that she
was rejected by so many Christian groups
because these are many of the same
groups that love CS Lewis and it's
interesting to me that so many people
across the world don't read Rowling or
or dislike growling because the magical
idea but she actually creates a very
religious argument and there through
Harry I mean his life the story we hear
of it starts at age 11 very similar to
the Ministry of Christ he has a mother
whose name is Lily purity who sacrifices
herself for him he is considered the
chosen one and then he has a garden of
gethsemane moment where he doesn't want
to do what he's being asked to do but
then decides that he needs that he will
do it he sacrifices himself to Voldemort
when he does he is resurrected but again
that's a choice he chooses to come back
he doesn't have to and so that idea of
self-sacrifice because of love being the
salvation of human beings that's one of
the major messages in Rowley she's
arguing through Harry what it means to
be good morally good and that through
Dumbledore she argues that being morally
good isn't our abilities it isn't what
we're born with it's the choices that we
make with those abilities and the
choices the particular choice that she
brings up often or that Dumbledore
brings up often is the choice to love
Dumbledore says to Harry you have a
power the power of which the Dark Lord
knows not which is to love and
says yeah yeah the love he says yeah
that's remarkable considering what
you've been through your choice to love
is this amazing thing that is an
essentially Christian message and that
doesn't make the books solely Christian
but it should make them appealing to
Christians and at any rate because she's
using this idea that is biblical
it's beyond biblical as well but it's
heavily biblical the preceding program
is copyrighted by Emory University